[Music]
oh how gorgeous look upon the majesty
and the son of Kurama rex
to be a vault hunter means a life of
tough dirty bloody work it's a lot of
exhausting labor for that precious loot
and the vault hunters could do with a
little vacation in the final Borderlands
2 headhunter DLC pack called sir
hammerlock versus the son of Cromer axe
we see our fatigued anti-heroes take a
trip to beautiful wampum Island where
they hope to kick their feet up and
enjoy a fruity cocktail but just as soon
as you start feeling relaxed sir
hammerlock is snatched away by a neon
blue claw and dragged underground it's
time to get back to work not only is the
final piece of the holiday flavored
headhunter packs the biggest of them
it's easily the best it provides a
challenging story boss a hilarious side
mission a gorgeous new area to explore
and plenty of humorous narration as you
play you are joined by the original
vault hunters who pipe in through your
radio offering aid while providing
fantastically funny back and forth
dialogue a bright blue sky envelops the
beautiful paradise of wampum Island
which is home to sandy beaches jungle
flora an underwater dome and a colossal
water wheel the bright and varied
setting is a playground for equally
vibrant enemies like flying barking
insects and crab boyd's that snap at
your shins from under shallow pools of
water the dark recesses of the island
are inhabited by natives whom you battle
in their home village nestled deep
within a shattered dome these warriors
defend themselves with large wooden
shields while throwing spears
distracting you long enough for their
stunted witch doctors to fling spells in
your direction the slashing and biting
final foe is a formidable challenge but
besting him rewards you with a wealth of
loot to collect and chests to unlock
finishing a story mission isn't the end
of your island adventure with the story
boss gone a new enemy appears hungry for
vengeance
the optional quest isn't that strenuous
but as you come face-to-face with
assassins you must
cut down to size you'll be left in
stitches you don't know what to expect
to come out of these encounters so it's
worth taking the time to see each one to
the comical end this final content pack
ties up remaining loose ends in
marvelous fashion ending on a high note
with the future looking bright for the
battle-weary vault hunters perhaps now
they can start on that well-earned break
[Music]